- Let's now see if we
can tackle the questions.
The passage most strongly
suggests that researchers
at the Martin Prosperity Institute
share which assumption?
We saw the writer, he works for the Martin
Prosperity Institute.
And he's trying to quantify
how much cost there
is involved when people having to commute
every minute of cost.
Employees who work from home are
are more valuable to their employers
than employees that commute.
No, he's not saying that.
He's just saying, when
you commute, regardless
how valuable you are to
employer, you're just
wasting time, having stress, etcetera.
Employees whose commutes are shortened,
will use the time saved to
do additional, productive
work for their employers.
Ah, maybe.
Arguably, they could have used that time
to take a vacation,
have a break, de-stress.
They don't say this directly.
I mean this is interesting.
Let's read the other choices.
Employees can conduct business activities
such as composing memos or joining
conference calls while commutting.
I didn't get any sense that
they want people to work
while they're driving.
Employees who have lengthy commutes tend
to make more money than
employees that have
shorter commutes.
So they never made that argument.
So out of all these,
this one seems to be the best,
Employees whose commutes are shortened
will use their time saved
to do additional, productive
work for their employers.
And I'm a little bit on the fence of this
because they quantified
the number of hours
and they said if people work those hours,
that would be the value to the economy.
But they're not saying that
that would convert directly
to additional productive work.
It could be time for the
person to recharge, etcetera
It didn't into a lot of
detail with what the person
would do with that
time, it just quantified
that time in terms of lost work time.
But out of all of them,
I'll go with this one.
As used in line 51,
intense most nearly means,
Let's read line 51.
The coming decades will
likely see more intense
clustering of jobs,
innovations and productivity,
and a smaller number of
bigger city and city regions.
The clustering of jobs, they're talking
about a higher concentration
of things happening.
so, this is not talking about an emotional
clustering of jobs,
it's talking about a
concentrated clustering of jobs.
They're not saying a
brilliant or determined
clustering of jobs either.
For these you can literally
just replace the word
and see how it sounds.
And see if it changes the
meaning of what they were
trying to talk about.
Alright.
The next one.
Which claim about traffic congestion
is supported by the graph?
A. New York city commuters spend less time
annually delayed by
traffic congestions than
the average for very large cities.
No, that's not true, New
York spends more than
the average for very large ciites.
Los Angeles commuters
are delayed more hours
annually than traffic congestion, than are
commuters in Washington D.C.
No, they are not, D.C. is
the top right over here.
Commuters in Washington D.C. face greater
delays annually due to traffic congestion
than do commuters in New York City.
Yep, we see that in
Washington D.C. has the most
delays annually.
So I would go with that.
Commuters in Detroit
spend more time delayed
annually by traffic
congestion than do commuters
in Houston, Altanta, Chicago.
Detroit's near the bottom
of at least this list.
It actually has less delay
than Atlanta, Chicago
and Houston.